yeah hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing our keep at least if is replying
hey does supply against g6 are played
before for quite a while now I want to
avoid some transposition said that don't
like so much to move all the issue I
think if is our most precise for my
repertoire complicated to explain I
guess okay so we get a King's Indian
Petrosian system and our keep is playing
the main line up to this point no Knight
a six is the usual way to play now
Queenie a double should be seven of
those are normal 95 is less common not
not a mistake or anything but it is less
frequently seen yeah one issue is that
there is a funny idea here with we b3
Knight takes d4 that Kasparov has played
the Queen sacrifice I don't quite
remember
maybe I play would be one first okay so
avoided any Queen sacrifice okay and
these are moves that I play anyhow so it
doesn't really matter that much okay now
he's threatening g5 bishop g3 f4 so I
have to play a three and yeah generally
speaking an approach with f5 here
against the Petrosian is believed to be
less reliable because you usually don't
get ya much of an attack going black I
mean
like it does not get much of an attack
it going okay yeah it's kind of
interesting it seems like Quincy to
Knight f6 is getting quite a bit of
pressure against my thorn it's not
really very convenient I'm wondering
after Knight f6 my intention is to play
Bishop d3 which is very weird you
usually never allow to take take this
like trade oh it's not that wasn't on my
radar and it's also not not particularly
good to be honest and so how do we
punish that the most straightforward is
is to take and push the six that already
looks fairly or fairly terrible from
black well okay let's let's not
overthink it
yeah that doesn't go work at all I mean
if that was possible I wouldn't have
played the whole thing okay so I can
take c-51 take on e4 first
[Music]
yeah I'm taking here and I think this is
modern more dynamic
if it takes it Bishop chase I've got
rookie one Quincy three things coming
yeah dad
really I didn't think that should work
97 I see six is extremely weak but
okay but if I take a Trillium that
really accelerates his development which
I don't want to allow
you know but this is okay
I'm playing this in a very conservative
way now if I get let be 45 establish
that pawn bind maybe I had a more that
met maybe had more dynamic ways of
approaching this but if I get that in I
must be an excellent shape that isn't
Muslim I'm not going to offer it I mean
if he offers I might take it
come on really want to show how this is
continued
I sent the tape back more that I can do
did you lock out of it that's great but
then I should actually get the point
right left the game great and then then
you don't get a take back in case you
get back
oh people
yeah I might as well say something about
the game the whole that whole mean sorry
said that was very interesting that he
played with the Bishop to g5 and then
the knight to f6 putting more pressure
on you for I think what I probably have
played mmm it'd be too cautiously maybe
and you know I can actually put it on
the board but yeah I can I know I have
people acting like little kids maybe is
a little kid no anyhow here in this
particular situation you want to play b3
in this position B 3 a3 and not yet we
move the rook because it's not quite
clear that you need it the thing is
there's this move and I never bothered
to look at it and it always feels to me
in a blitz game that could be a problem
like not a problem objectively but it
looks a bit odd Black has two minor
pieces the e5 pawn and he will get the
diagonal open so yeah complicated
because peril played that in a rapid
game I think even against kramnik once
so it is it is it's not completely
terrible or anything it's needs to be
taken seriously I never bothered to look
at it so I avoided this just for
practical purposes and oh this seems
fairly normal Bishop f6 I retreated yeah
here Queen c2 is not so accurate
according to the engine once the cone
ib5 you have certainly 95 comes into
consideration is a fairly normal moon
but it's funny that like here the
automated analysis him that somebody
triggered
gives 0.34 Quincy - while Quincy - even
like stock fashion gives 0.7 and the
dead looked like a war museum give up
the strong Bishop
yeah King g7 yeah until you have more
than one way to do it but this is the
most straightforward it completely
breaks open the center and sc6 is not
possible as we have seen in the game you
don't really have a good movers black
then you had get those squares now
opened up for the night and in the
center yeah it's it's it's fantastic for
white and he's got the very weak very
weak King side him so this is normally
takes at 95 I mean yeah you can do OB 6
ok better was not a form very
straightforward but strongly ok I mean I
still have a huge advantage its blitz
chess yeah I suspected that before it's
not the most powerful move but if I get
c5 and it's so easy to play there was a
question here by Superman's dad oh six I
mean what about Quincy three can you
sign and take only five sure yeah that
is a that is one of the more concrete
approaches and like Here I am
it looks very good and in the engine
agrees that is a plus two it was just
like I tend to use a static solution
especially in blitz chess I saw I get
before I get c5 in and if I can get this
the game is essentially over long term
on that I'm on that and it's looks it
looks like rubbish absolute for black so
it should be a win and now a mile
slipped and then left the game instead
of taking play for a take pic request
yeah anyhow thanks a lot for watching